all right so now that we've used uh
something like the statistics module now
would be a pretty good time to talk
about um
this syntax for importing modules and
all the kind of tricks that we can do
with importing modules because if you're
not familiar you might see some example
code and you might not understand how
they're doing something or how they're
able to reference a module or a function
within a module without actually saying
the module and all this stuff so i'm
going to show you guys some of the
various ways that you can import a
module
to do exactly how what you want i guess
um so with that uh let's go ahead and
get started so we're gonna go ahead and
i guess we can get rid of this
and so you've seen for now import
statistics and so the idea here is we
import statistics and then we can use
this module now module is just a python
script for the most part some modules
are a little more in depth but this is a
python script and so i can even show you
guys this um we can go to your computer
c
uh python34
lib and within lib is where you're going
to find all of your
kind of vanilla modules the ones that
come with python and then all your
third-party modules genu generally are
going to be installed under site
packages so these are all your
third-party modules now statistics comes
with it so we can actually just find
stat statistics whoops statistics and we
can find say for example the mean uh
module we can search let me bring it
down here search for like define mean
like that
and here is our mean function so this is
the block of code that is run when we
reference mean okay so that's all it is
it's just a python script okay so we'll
get out of here minimize this
and now we can go over
some things so
statistics while not super long it's
kind of a long name we might maybe we
don't want to type out statistics every
single time it's kind of a tedious thing
to type out so when you do this you can
say import statistics as s and now every
time you want to reference statistics
you just have to type s so instead of
statistics.variance you could do s dot
variance we could run that
uh we didn't have it printing out so
let's go ahead and print x
and now you get your variance of 4.85
okay so uh we're able to reference it
just with a simple s
now the other thing that you can do as
well is say you don't even want to type
s you just uh want to say variance well
you can do that as well
and that's going to be
from static statistic this is why we
want to do it as s it's a pain to type
so from statistics
import variance and now you don't even
need an s dot now you could reference it
straight as variants like that
okay so you can do that
so now the next thing that we can do of
course though is from statistics import
variance if you don't want to type
variance you could say import variance
as v right so now instead of variance we
can just say x equals v example list run
that and again that still works
now the next thing that we want to do
like let's say we want to import a few
things from statistics so variance
and we want mean
so x equals variance example list
y equals mean
example
list
and then we'll have it print
y and so here under this uh we can see
that we were able to use these commas
right so when we go and run it we've we
were successful in
um
pulling out the two functions from this
module and leaving the rest and then
we're also referencing them as you know
the function name because we can just
import statistics in the new statistics
dot and we when we import statistics
we've imported everything anyways
so
but we still what if we don't want to
type variant to mean well we can do
still like this import variance as v
mean
as m
so we can change this to v change this
to m
and everything works as we hope
so
we're able to do that now the last thing
i want to cover is what if you know we
want to import everything from
statistics but we don't want to have to
put statistics dot
well we can do something else we can say
from statistics import asterisk and what
the asterisk means is everything it's a
form of regular expression that just
means everything
so basically we're importing everything
as if we typed everything out so now we
can say
variance
mean like this we never actually
imported them but we
we said import everything and then in
this scenario we don't actually have to
type statistics either so we can do this
and that works as uh as expected so
that's it um obviously we can't really
necessarily get away with import
everything as because everything can't
have the same name but we can't import
everything just in case you wanted to do
that so there's a few of the examples of
how we can do
the import importing of of modules and
the functions within them
depending on what exactly you're trying
to do with that module if you want
everything in that module or maybe you
want one thing in that module or maybe
you want to import that module as if you
had written that code you know in the
functions within your single script but
you want to
have it in its own separate script
whatever
you can do all that so if you guys have
any questions or comments feel free to
leave those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time